all right point number one
one of the biggest differences between
men and women and
i think both sexes tend to have some
difficulty accepting this
is that when it comes to uh women
we're more concerned with their past
whereas
with men women are more concerned with
our futures
they're not they're not particularly
concerned if you've got a notch count of
it's not that significant to them in
fact in some cases it's almost desirable
for women to know that men have had some
experience and they understand the
dynamics between men and
men and women on the other hand though
they're they're more concerned with
men's futures what is your ability to
provision and provide in the future can
you make it rain
do you know how to make bank you know uh
are you a competent guy that can get
stuff done are you the type that
you know when uh difficulties enter your
life
you quit you sulk you complain and you
whine about it
women want to know that they're with a
strong guy that
again can make it rain that can get
things done that can solve problems that
has competency skills
it's been that way throughout history
and it's always going to be that way
that's never going to change
it doesn't matter how much of the uh
feminist indoctrination narrative that
we all take in society
that tries to level the playing field
and make it a blank slate equal
sort of egalitarian layout where men and
women are identical
we're not we're quite different and men
on the other hand
are concerned about a women's past and
as you should be
most of you guys out there want to get
into some kind of long-term relationship
with a woman or want to have
more positive interactions with women
and some of you guys still make an
incredibly bad
choice allowing or inviting problem
women with problem pass
into your life um she's she's been
around the block
guess what guys she she belongs to the
streets you know she's gonna have
difficulty
uh committing to you on a long-term
basis there's been plenty of studies
done around this
and men with a lot of experience versus
women with a lot of
you know intimate experience out there
are two different stories
you've got to be aware of that again so
to distill that concept point number one
is uh
women are more concerned about men's
future men
should be more concerned about her past
if they're evaluating her for a future
if they're if they're thinking about
inviting
that woman into their life on a more
intimate basis
you